So um by way by way of starting off I mean you know and we're we're gonna edit this stuff so
whatever but I mean by way of starting off I thought uh I mean I want to throw it to Caddy
but I don't want you to have to jump in right away so I was gonna see uh why other folks might
be interested in Deleuze or this book in particular as a sort of like what what we're
looking to get out of it and you know why why we're doing this thing why we're starting into
this thing I mean for the rest of us like particularly after the you know the Hegel I
mean there's some I mean I don't know like for me at least having spent the last six months reading
Hegel and then moving to this I feel like I can fucking breathe again yeah yeah for sure so it's
like oh yes this is you know sort of something inventive and playful and funny you know um as
opposed to just like meticulously um serious and plotting you know yeah um so yeah but I mean look
you know I mean I I enjoyed the Hegel thing I feel like I turned a lot of corners in terms of my
sort of what we would loosely call kind of appreciation of the movement of dialectical
thinking in ways that I was so resistant to it and you know the podcast will kind of I think tell
that story at least on my side of it um for me obviously to lose this stuff that I've been reading
for you know 20 years and uh this is a book that uh I mean Nathaniel and I did this about
what was it about 10 plus years ago or something like that yeah eight ten years ago that we we went
through chunks of it and I mean obviously we need to talk some about the structure of the thing but
simply put it just occurred to me like this is clearly a kind of proto version of the plateau
right like I mean this is he's doing plateaus and he's doing them you know it's not series in the
sense of a linear series and it's just sort of I I realized in reading this like without thinking
about this is the model for the style book I'm writing right now like I'm doing just chunks of
five to eight page chunks and I've got like 15 of them or whatever so far but you know like it is
this kind of thinking and I'm also doing it in such a way where like it's not just some of the things
would be one large chunk but I broke them into two but I don't have the first one first and the
second one second I have the second one for you know so like so that the transmission would go
backwards and forwards which in this case just like Thousand Plateaus there's no real order
uh in which to read it and it doesn't really I think in terms of the series it doesn't really matter
um or rather another way of saying it is it matters a lot which order you read it in but there isn't a
right one um so you know I I think in terms of and we can get to work to this towards the end but
like in terms of where we want to go from here I think jumping around is a perfectly viable strategy
rather than kind of insistently hammering through uh I've always but that's just I've always a I've
always appreciated that uh stylistically about Deleuze just because it's the emphasis is obviously not
on well it's not uh particularly on comprehension it's about sort of sampling and finding what you
know you can attach to and that's the same as it is in A Thousand Plateaus obviously so I think I mean
at least for me reading Deleuze now I'm seeing increasingly similarities between his thinking
and Hegel's I know that for a majority of the the Hegel podcast we were kind of doing this
a lot of those episodes we would do kind of a compare and contrast you know with the styles of
thinking and um I mean I would say personally I have probably like a cursory knowledge at least
compared to to John and Nathaniel uh with Deleuze I don't know about how much you've read Caddy of of
his stuff but I've only read through your classes John you know so so I mean it's not I don't I don't have
a comprehensive you know knowledge of the Deleuze oeuvre but I am excited to kind of refine these these
comparisons that we've been making um for the last few months uh between those kinds of thinking you
know affirmation negation dialectic you know play that kind of those kind of well dialectics really I
mean obviously the Stoic dialectic is a different oh yeah for sure one but he's very interested in
dialectics as the the means of of the event right so for sure for sure right yeah I only have the
the greatest hits under my belt um but I've always a pretty heavy playlist
yeah that's true that's true um but I've I've always known that I had to come to The Logic of
Sense because I mean first off if if you're going to study something like doxa you have to you just
have to live in the realm of becoming like that's just your metaphysics right like it's just becoming
there's really um being being only has an option as becoming playful you know counter whatever
Interlocutor, right, um, so I always knew that and I was just so struck reading this, um, by how
by how apt it is for kind of the, I don't know what you want to call it, the post-human turn or whatever
but also just kind of thinking about bodies in relation to digitality. I mean, Deleuze in this
already and I'm I might tear up because I I'm really excited and that's just what happens when I get
really excited like about research, um, but like it's it's already incredibly clear to me that for him
sense makes the body sensing kind of this this this digital virtual thing, you know, like it extends the
body way past the body, right, and and it just makes so much sense in thinking about, um, bodies encountering
digitality and then digitality encountering bodies and and all of the sense that kind of goes into that
so this is just a very timely thing, I think. Yeah, yeah, I I totally agree with this. The the way it
resonates with post-human thought, I mean I think all the Deleuze stuff does that, but this one particularly
does just because you have to radically rethink the way that he's, you know, articulating the the term
body which like I think the the challenge for me is always to never think of that as exclusively reducive
to human bodies or even living bodies, but to think about like an infinite set of overlapping or like
articulations as body or individuation as the making of a body, so like you get, you know, like
what we would in sort of more common parlance call like digital bodies or digital human bodies or whatever
I mean you can get an infinite set of those things and that I I really do like that I also like I mean
because I agree with you, John, that the sort of plateau series, um, comparison is is there and um you
know when I first sort of approached A Thousand Plateaus and I read that you you know, you can read
a plateau in any direction and the direction that you read it really matters but you know, it doesn't but
it also doesn't matter and I mean I I didn't quite appreciate the power of that until I worked through
this a little bit more where like the the reason for the reason that reading it through in one particular
direction as opposed to another one really matters because he outlines the sort of the process of the
sense making like the way like reading two series in relationship to each other sort of acts as an event
that redistributes and re-evaluates the entire like it resonates through the entire body that you have
have read
there's almost well I mean there's clearly like an ethics attached to um that kind of invitation to
sample and switch around and not read in a linear fashion like it's not demanding that you comprehend the
full text which I think is just a clear sort of it's so much less uh domineering because most texts are
trying to now Deleuze does try to intimidate you not maybe not explicitly but you know to the to the
extent that like the language is really dense and the concepts are like sort of all over the place but
I do think I mean I'm going to try to keep the comparisons to Hegel to a minimum because I know this
is a separate thing but comparatively like when you contrast that just that simple ethic you know to
Hegel's where he's he's commanding your attention and he wants you to read it sort of like like a
what do you call it like in a narrative fashion, you know, front to back linear, the teleology, I mean just
simply giving a series is antithetical to that and and invites the reader in a much different way so
yeah, yeah, well I mean Hegel's is very clearly unidirectional right and this is not um and it says
so from the beginning and it's one of the things that I found myself paying attention to was because
interestingly enough there's a there's an intensely authoritative voice here which is
you know the Stoics invented the event, right? That's it. These are no one did this before like no one like
they invented a new way of thing, you know, like um, and so he has these incredibly audacious authoritative
sentences in the midst of a thinking that is you know recursive and um multiple and disorienting and
so it's it's just this really interesting kind of juxtaposition of on because it's it seems kind
of ludic but it also seems kind of like insistently ludic, you know, well I mean in like to compare it
to Hegel whereas I feel like Hegel would want to substantiate that claim or he would want it to carry
some kind of like weight of truth I I feel like Deleuze really only cares about the chain of effects
that the authoritativeness is like the authoritativeness here is a style that is going to
uh resonate with what what follows from it so it's more like a launching off point or a riff that as
it is like a claim to some kind of representational truth like so this is a common style yourself you'll
find it right like this is a common stylistic move that he repeats in other places but uh there were a
couple of instances of this and what we read so far where he'll make a sort of claim that is I don't
really understand exactly what the claim is but it's a very assertive claim and then he'll quote
from Lewis Carroll a quote that makes no fucking sense whatsoever as an explanation of that claim
but it's just presented there as like see see here's here's here's my evidence to support the thing that i was
saying when the evidence makes no sense to support the thing and you and well right of course and then
then you realize ah he's doing that right like that this is part of this is part of the mo of of the
writing so i was thinking about this when you were uh Nathaniel when you were talking about the body
question and you know it's really explicit in the Nietzsche book about like the convergence of two forces
forms a body that's what a body is is the convergence of force it doesn't matter whether it's a social body
uh an organic body and inorganic none of that matters it's just the convergence of forces that creates
any any sense of what a body is um and so and i think that that's true in here as well and you
can see there's kind of a lack of interest in this so-called materiality of the body part of things
you know in its traditional configuration right you know or it's just one of many it's it's
one of an infinite array of possible arrangements of right there's kind of there's kind of a paradox there
where it's like the this like sensing and senses you know takes Alice and creates this kind of
virtual sheen right um and extends Alice beyond Alice body per se right right but but then but by
doing so it also draws attention to just how bodily that body absolutely right and so there's that play
incorpore the incorporeality which again will play out in Thousand Plateaus in order word stuff and
the sort of the language version you know later on uh with Guattari but you see it you see it all here
the sort of emphasis on the so-called incorporeal dimension of of the two dimensions the incorpore i mean
this is where like you know like i mean we've talked about this before but you know what has always drawn me
about Deleuze Derda and those types of the the Nietzschean lineage of thinkers is while most thinkers are like
given stuff how do things change is the usual orientation of thinking like given that there's
stuff how do things change and the the interest or the intervention of these types of thinkers is
exactly the opposite of that which is like given that shit is becoming all the time how does how do
things ever stick together right like how do you ever have how do you ever have something like a politics
i mean how do you know given that you've got so it's just a it is presuming i mean as caddy was saying
before that kind of ontology you know in quotation marks of becoming as kind of prior so you have like
how do you ever get stuff
would it be worth reflecting on a little bit about the concept of the podcast and i mean the idea of
thinking with and where it's because we had several explicit conversations about this early on in the
Hegel tapes we need to come up with a cool name for this one by the way it's the Hegel tapes i think i
like that name but we talked about this you know early on and then sporadically and i think it'll be
helpful for us to reflect on it a little bit more but i think it'll also be good a good moment to do
it introducing caddy to the to the mix uh so that she can have a sense of what's been going on and where
they're going and you know she has to jump in and change the dynamic of it um what what's your take
on how like i mean the the one obvious change that happened is in the first five to six episodes and
we've been doing this for like yeah six over six months um the first half of the episodes we took like
what we took 10 paragraphs for a reading and we were we stuck pretty close to to the text and after we
started to get the groove we we opened up that like we started reading no we were reading like
two we were just doing a a paragraph a paragraph an episode yeah that's right yeah and then it took us
it took us three months to get through i don't know 10 pages yeah wow i'm not even joking and then and
then when we got really like crazy we were doing 10 pages 10 parents that was just wow you know
yeah like that was towards towards the end it was like no holds barred man we're gonna do 10 pages
for next week well we had to start moving just to get to the master slave stuff you know we had to
we had to make some improvements we realized this could be our life
we did this for seven months and we read 140 pages yeah wow and we met pretty much every week i mean
there were a couple of exceptions but we met pretty much every week so that's and so like compared to
that you know we're starting off in warp drive with um we did 11 pages i was like this is insane
too much i i i like i mean i was able to read it twice and read some of the williams and read the
first like that's what i mean i spent i spent a good 10 to 12 hours on these 11 pages with not the 11
Pages but just this sort of circle around them to other kinds of stuff. Yeah, yeah, I didn't do any
reading around it, but I read like the 10 pages and I immediately was like, oh fuck, we're gonna have
to speed this along because I need this now. Like, y'all, I I can jump in again for like the next 10 pages
but I am I'm going like, I'm gonna go and then I'm gonna come back and it'll be perfect, right? Because
my senses will be altered, my body's will be altered, you know, that's right.
So, yeah, Caddy will just come back every episode with a slightly crazier, like, wilder look in her eye.
I've been beyond you. You don't know what I've seen.
So are you going to be using this for a book project, or how are you? Oh, yeah, the big book
project coming up. Yeah, okay, you're finishing it. You're you're you're revising the disc, right, into
book form? Yeah, yeah. So, um, the draft of my book is due, uh, July, and I'm about to go into research
leave, and the the book project is basically, um, you know, reclaiming doxa to kind of think about opinions in
in terms of the the digital age, uh, and this chapter that I'm just starting, um, originally was gonna all
each chapter is kind of like doxa and blank, like what's some site that we can kind of rethink through
opinion and to make sense of to make sense of some weird digital phenomena, right? Um, so it's like doxa and
isolation, doxa and space, and now I'm at what I thought was going to be doxa and the body but now it is
very clear to me as I as I manically was texting Nathaniel it's very clear to me that this is doxa and
sense, um, which of course makes sense, right, given like of course, you know, we always talk about opinion
in terms of of sense, right? Um, and this was also the chapter where I was going to kind of think about
what happens when people fall for misinformation, um, and fall or or don't understand online satire and
it's going to be kind of the conspiracy theory chapter, QAnon, nice. So QAnon, yeah. And so, yeah,
I mean, so like Deleuze with with sense and nonsense and that kind of territorial breach
um, like that is just going to be incredibly incredibly useful and and of course reverberating
reverberating through all this is is Arendt and and thinking about doxa as this sixth sense, right? And
that was really timely as well because, you know, she's thinking about sense, that sense as something that
fits us into some kind of common world, which is mind-blowing. That's, that's mind-blowing to me.
Well, it's definitely that Deleuze takes on I think like like straight on the I mean that the notion of
the good sense as like the right direction through a like the the logical field of something and then
the common sense common brings disparate parts and sort of like establishes a common from the uncommon
like that's what he's gonna, that's what he totally fucks with in this and that he definitely like
explicitly and Difference and Repetition especially like those are the the primary targets of those
books are good sense and common sense. Yeah, and with Arendt, I mean with her emphasis on the sort of
like the polis is the site of action that creates a space of remembering and the possibility of the who to
to to emerge. I mean she's pretty committed to the space of the common. I mean, you know, yeah, I mean it'll
I mean I I I think that they'll be very interesting people to put in conversation with you, uh, but
yeah, I mean this is this is also kind of the the chapter that that rethinks topical invention, which
is just also really perfect because of course that's relational and really bodily, right? It's an expressing and
not stating and so in that expressing even when people fall through misinformation that's that's
inventive but it's not um definitive, right? It's not it's it's that kind of sense of sense as not fixed
but in fact discovery, right? Like I I really think that reading Deleuze is making me understand the
inventive dimensions of sense in a way that I just wow yeah yeah um yeah so it's it's gonna be fun and
it's gonna move me away from you know that that common reading of Aristotle being somebody who's
interested in common sense no Aristotle was not interested in common sense Aristotle was interested
in uncommon sense like what what the elites say is uncommon like that is not right you know
you know right the konoy? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I was gonna say I kind of like the idea of the uh um
doxa in the body still though if you just started writing about the body in the way that and so that
like when when body people come to read your thing they're like I don't think these are the bodies we're
writing about she's saying that word but I don't think that word means what I think that word means
no that's true. Yeah, let's start him with that then because I mean I think that the the question of the
bi-directionality of sense uh is I mean obviously he leads with it um and it's going to be a constant
refrain because I I hear you don't necessarily have the ontology that you do in A Thousand Plateaus but
It's the same thinking, which is that, and it, I mean, if you could say it this way, you don't get
recognition and identification without misrecognition and misidentification, that they are
they're simultaneously parts and and this is, I mean, the ontological version of it being like
you've got your plane of emissants facing the body without organs and facing the strata
and so you don't form strata without also forming a body without organs, so it's not like
you've got this sort of like, you know, the the heady identified recognizable thing without having
dispersion, I mean, you, there's no, you don't get to pick one, right? Like, you, you know, there's never like
hey, let's be on the liberatory side, like there's no side, right? Like, you, you, you're only ever working in
in uh on both both dimensions, if you say it that way. I mean, he attributes it to Plato, but I think
interestingly, there's just a little shift from Plato here, like, I mean, on the on page one where he says
Plato, Plato asks us to choose between these two dimensions. One is the recognition identification
or I would call that Hegel, sorry, but recognition identification side and then the mat going mad
batshit crazy side, um, but that they're not two different things, right? That they are, um, that there is a
seamless connection uh among those or another way of saying it is that, you know, like, that those recognizable
identifiable things are comprised or are made up of nothing but going mad, right? Like, that that that's
all they are. And that's to me, that's that's a really big and important idea. I mean, to to say
that they sort of calcified and edifying moments are not opposed to the becoming mad, right? They they
are made up of them. Everything. This is where you get like Foucault's there's nothing but resistance. It's
like no, because power is made up of nothing but that's all it is is just force, forces of resistance.
And whereas and and look, a lot of political thinkers, that doesn't make sense because we must see them
as opposed forces or opposed sides, and I feel like that's one of the really cool, I mean, we're we start
with that, right? We start with you don't get bigger without getting smaller, right? Right. Calcification is
always already a becoming calcified, right? Like, it never is calcified and it's never, I mean, it's it is
always in the process of slowing down or capturing more, but there's never it's never stopped, right?
So it's never cut off from everything else. I mean, to use the language of being and becoming that we've
been using, um, you know, in the second page, uh, halfway down that first full paragraph, um, after he's talking
about the the sort of the different tensions between the model one, the copy and the model copy and the
the simulacrum he he turns through the Cratylus and the language, um, it's still via Plato and just
like halfway down and after he asked that question, sometimes Plato wonders whether this pure becoming
might not have a very peculiar uh relation to language. This seems to be uh one of the principal
meetings of the Cratylus. Could this relation be perhaps essential to language as in uh in the case
of a flow of speech or a wild discourse which would incessantly slide over its referent without ever
stopping, or might there not be two languages and two sorts of names, one designating the pauses and
rests which receive the action of the idea and the other expressing the movements or rebel becomeings
or further still is it not possible that there are two distinct dimensions internal to language in general
one always concealed by the other yet continuously coming to the aid or subsisting under the other
I mean, to me that was like a really, that's that last one yeah yeah. I mean, the yeah, the end of that
is what I I really latched on to because I mean one of the the moves of the sort of like becoming ontologist
is sort of the like, I'm done with being, get rid of it, everything is becoming, and here you say like
you can't think one without the other. That's right. I mean, you know, when we started talking about flows
and becoming and whatever else it's you're always the capacity to talk about is always only vis-a-vis
the hypostasizing of those forces, right? And so like the activation of a force it's always going to run
into something else which is always going to create some kind of resistance to use the language that you're
using before. So so this is why people need to become better readers of Plato I think because it's it's
not it's never that distinct for him even when you know the dialogue whatever dialogue there is like
even when it seems like the distinction is going to be made and cemented and fixed for sure, right?
There's always it's always thrown into relief by something um kind of poetic about the dialogue or
something you know like about arrangement or even you know the fact that the speaker ends something
with a question mark, right? You know, there's that I I always think about this amazing moment in the
Timaeus where Timaeus is kind of like okay, you know, first of all we have to distinguish between being
And becoming, right, that that there's the intelligible and then the not intelligible, um, and then he
You know, he's kind of like, uh, maybe we only know that there's intelligible because we sense it
Um, through through the stuff that is becoming, and then he's like, oh, but, you know, it's fine, like
No worries that that's just my opinion, maybe it might, you know, um, and he ends that moment with it's
probably just empty talk all the way down, and it's just this great moment where becoming and being like
He knows that that's the fundamental question and cannot make a distinction in of itself, yeah, so and
I mean, to to your point there, Caddy, right above what Nathaniel read is that he's like, look, this
This dualism is not that of the intelligible and the sensible, right? Like, it is, it is something that
circulates through both the intelligible and the sensible, like what I'm interested you know what he's
interested in here is something that's not reducible to that kind of that kind of distinction. I mean, he
doesn't bring up the Timaeus, but it's it's the same kind of thinking here. I mean, look, Dera's word for
it is difference, right? Uh, Deleuze's later word for it is desire, uh, Foucault's word for it is right
like it is this sort of pre-ontological movement. I mean, I always feel like the illocutionary is is a
perfectly good word for it as well, right? Like, that that sort of force of movement prior that doesn't
have a particular telos, right? That is the condition of possibility for all of those kinds of distinctions
between sensible and intelligible, etc., etc. Well, unlike the uh with the Hegel tapes, um, uh, in addition to the
fact that I'm just interested in in reading this stuff and enjoy talking about it with y'all, I actually
have a project kind of more explicitly connected to The Logic of Sense, and it's, I mean, it's a Platonic
one. Caddy's read a draft of it, and and I mean that's exactly what I I want to do is sort of activate a
little bit more of a destabilizing thread that I see running throughout the Phaedrus where like
writing in in that discourse writing really sort of undoes its representational sense, and I mean in
the way that it is plugged into the myth of the charioteers, right, writing it writing itself does
that not some additional operation that one has to do, correct? Writing writing itself both establishes
the the fixed coordinates and undoes the establishing of the fixed coordinates. That's Derrida, right?
Well, and and this is what I mean. I want to focus on the the myth and I want to focus on the stuff
that I mean like Derrida largely ignores the speeches, right? He focuses on the myth of writing, uh, at the end
and he focuses on a few topological things, but he he largely ignores the speeches because that's usually
what gets all of the sure the attention, and I want to try to to stitch the two sides together a little bit
more, um, and I I mean, I yeah, I kind of want to read I want to I want to try to create an event within the
text that is going to sort of produce a new sense of writing that does not eradicate the sort of reductive
version of writing that he comes that that that is often gets taken away from it, but it sort of works
along side of it, where all of those valuations of you know mere uh remembrance and um you know repetition
and um uh like monuments and yeah, that all of those things sort of get re-evaluated as the life-giving
force and energy of of writing itself that these and I end up working as sort of like
the the catalysts of of the movement of thinking itself, where the fact that they are contentless
is precisely what allows them to to spark the movement of thinking. Right, now I need to figure out
I mean wait for me turning to this book I don't know how explicitly I want to bring that up, I don't
know how I I mean this is my personal side project that I'll welcome y'all's uh advice on is I want to
figure out how to to I what I don't want to do is say like here's the logic of sense it's my lens for
reading Plato here's what here's my hermeneutic reading of Plato vis-a-vis The Logic of Sense
because that what could be more antithetical to this project than doing that, but I don't
I haven't I have not figured out how to finesse the relationship better though have you have you read
the appendix to this book the okay because that's the simulacrum one, right? That was really formed
it my uh my the Plato the reading of the sophists that I do in the invention book, um, that's all taken
out of that essay and uh and it was also I mean it really forced me to think through Plato's logic
of the copy and simulacrum in the Republic and in other places, but it was really really helpful to me
because it allowed me to realize and this is you know how Deleuze works by just saying things and
not explaining them very often and uh but being able to understand where because he says a lot of
times that the simulacrum is not a second order copy, um, right, and and realizing why that's crucial
because the copy for Plato has an internal resemblance to the model whereas the simulacrum
And the example that he gives of the simulacrum is the the large statue, right? Like, a statue that's
built so large that you have to, and Williams, I think, uses this example as well. And for me, I
after part I'm like, why is that different? What's different about a large statue? And I realized the
thing that's different about it is that it brings in the appearance of someone looking at it, right?
Like, um, in other words, a human perceiving a large statue is part of how the simulacrum works. So the
perception, right, it's a different exactly. And so it and it it introduces a new variable where the
model and the copy are concerned with internal consistency, uh, you know, the copy is internally
consistent with the model. The simulacrum is externally consistent, right? Like, it it introduces that external
realm of appearances for a body, a human seeing a large statue, and that changes everything.
Right? There's a different selection of difference in the repetition of it. Like, I mean, it's the selection
and the repetition outside of the of the eternal return, whereas like these are sort of like
corresponding points and then repeating that difference produces this kind of thing. Like, when
when that's right internal coherence, this is what comes out of it when that difference gets repeated when
external coherence, external appearance, and copy, then this is what comes out of it, right? Well, once you
introduce, once you once you start thinking about external coherence, all bets are off, right? Because with
external coherence you now have uh uh anything could be your body that's perceiving, right? In this case
it's a human and it's a large statue, but that doesn't that's just one possible thing. With internal coherence, you
have a telos, which is I'm going to get this internally correct. With external coherence correctness, it just
goes out the window, right? Like, there's no there's just no question of correctness. There's a question of
fidelity to a perception. Ah, well, fidelity to perception, now there's a limitless number of ways that that
could that could be thought, and to me that's where the simulacrum is is truly dangerous from a certain
Platonic perspective, right? Right. And truly enabling from another Platonic perspective, right? Like, it's
because it's it really is it it is limitless, right? It is it is structurally limitless. Like, anything
could be that body and that perception, you know? Anything can serve that role, and now you're talking
about creating a statue that's going to look appropriate to infinite number of perspectives. Well, you know, that
introduces so much malleability that you lose any sense of like the the impossibility of a relationship
to the model other than through its external coordinate, and that changes everything, right? I mean,
I wonder then if Plato is the better figure for the the post-human turn, right? I mean, if you're talking
about the the kind of complexity of that that particular view of his ontology makes him, it seems like
somebody would have championed him by now. Well, that's what I mean. That's Derrida's pharmacon essay does
exactly that. I realize that. But in rhetoric, right, he's always vilified. I mean, at least traditionally,
I mean, my dream has always been to walk into my classical rhetoric class on day one and say, like,
everyone knows Plato's the great champion of rhetoric, right? Like, yeah, everyone knows that. Like, that's just
what the field believes, and in other words, installing in students who don't know any better, like,
that's the starting point. The starting point is he is the champion uh of rhetoric rather than the bad
guy that we need to overcome, you know? I've always yeah yeah we have rhetorical theory because of Plato.
Yeah, well, I've always found I've always found Plato more interesting to read than Aristotle, and to
me that's enough to champion him over Aristotle, you know what I mean? Like, that's just just
experientially the reading the reading experience is better. So I'm gonna go with Plato. No, I agree. But
see, that's so but interestingly enough because your affinity for Hegel, Hegel to read to me reads much
more Aristotelian, like way more Aristotelian, you know? Yeah, I suppose so, but I I still think that I
I mean, we don't have this is gonna take us down a whole other I mean, I still think Hegel is is doing
something stylistically completely different from Aristotle. But anyway, but anyway, we don't have to do
that today, but yeah, I mean, I I think there there are certainly good reasons bracketing the certain the
history of philosophy and the history the sort of, you know, shorter history of rhetoric. There are good
reasons for reading Plato, you know, as Nathaniel, as you're wanting to read him, right? And and saying, like,
this is simply right, um, or or at very least it's a way more interesting starting point for thinking
about the field rather than theory of forms, transcendent aristocratic politics, right? Like all of those
all of those usual attributions which by the way I've all I've been curious if recently if that's
changed because you know now that we see what the polis actually is like, right, in the last few years
Uh I just wonder if that aristocratic aversion to the demos makes a lot more sense, right? I mean, you
know because I mean when I was in grad school it was like, you know, Plato hates the demos he doesn't
want the people involved and what an elitist and all this stuff and I was I was always the
asshole in class being like have you met the demos? And now I think that you know more people on the left
are like oh yeah the demos is maybe not such a great thing like has that caused people to sort of
reevaluate the alleged elitism or like what's exactly wrong with elitism again because, you know,
I'm just saying my faith in democracy was eradicated like when I was 19 or 20 and I first read The Republic
and Plato like made the claim about the like I don't want the demos baking my bread I want
I don't want a baker breaking my damn my damn bread but yes I do too I do too
Um, you know, I look, I mean, you know, my version of this you guys have gotten it plenty of times but
like, you know, there's a certain certain style or dimension of elitism that's like what's wrong with
that? Yeah, for certain styles of it. Yeah, I mean it was really really hard to, I mean, yeah, to parse them
out but yeah it's certainly not I don't I don't simply have a I don't have a simple aversion to it
I I mean I'm thinking about, you know, I mean as much as I love it at the end of that Um,
Plato's Pharmacy essay and uh the little anecdote uh Derrida gives of you know that yeah where you
can lose it Plato loses control over shit right I I mean even that isn't Derrida walking in and
saying everyone knows that Plato is the great champion of of rhetoric even that is like I mean it it
characterizes Plato as neurotically compulsively trying to trying to control like yeah just sift out
these two repetitions and so that he can adequately judge the good from the bad and what Plato or I
mean what Derrida in many ways is doing is saying like look as a sort of inherent feature of writing
and iteration writ large is like that project is impossible and even to the brightest mind it's
going to drive them batty and that I mean I think that you could come you could begin with an even
more affirmative starting point that doesn't begin with like everyone knows Plato is the guy that does
this thing oh by the way his writing does something perhaps his writing you know sort of conspires
against him and you know instead like I mean you have to be careful not to reintroduce a certain kind
of intentionality into the thing but I do think that you could like the the the the the general sense of
the thing could be shifted that there is a version of writing where like if you treat writing as a
container of of knowledge then you should be really suspicious of it as that thing right but I mean the
more I read the Phaedrus the more I think that it's just a version of writing that Plato is is sort of
trying to undo and then he's actually modeling another far more interesting version of writing and
part of it is hidden in the critique Um, now again I don't know how I don't want to turn but that's where
you can I mean you could the terminology there I mean the the last sentence that you read to is are
there not two dimensions within all language? Right? Right? There there there's a dimension of fixing and there's a
dimension of unfixing and it's not like oh for this part of the Plato's writing he's doing fixing and
for this part he's unfixing it's no they're the same always happen they're the same moments right
and that that's where you know I mean that that I think maybe it's that second point that is the
hard one to think about right like it's one thing to say well there are times where Plato is more
exploratory and times when he's more fixated but to say no no it's when he's most fixated that he's also most
exploratory that's I think maybe the harder thing that's what I'm saying about like as a place to
jump in that two dimensions at once like as Alice gets bigger she also gets smaller but not because
she's getting bigger and smaller at the same time so I mean that that to me is I mean it's crucial in
terms of this is that there you don't get to pick one right you don't get to go with the just getting
bigger I only want to get bigger or I only want you know to fix it's you know well that
that's always yeah yeah that simultaneity is just difficult to accept I think for most theorists
even good theorists you know it's like it's either there are bodies or there are no bodies or there's
consistency or only inconsistency why can't you hold them together you know it yeah it I mean it feels
necessary in The Logic of Sense to do that obviously he foregrounds that that move you know I think
what I want to do then is really drop that in spite of himself like in spite of Plato you know this is
still operating at the level of writing and just like drop the intentionality all together like no
everyone knows that this is like these things are happening at the same time and who cares if Plato
was working against it or with it or whatever else I'm not going to focus on or you just have a have a
I mean I would just talk about that I would just, you know, like just address that question is the
tendency would be to phrase this as Plato's writing working against what Plato is trying to do
I want to resist this because that presumes a distinction between the two that I that I want
to question, you know, yeah, yeah, I I definitely no matter how you handle it I definitely think you need
to use Logic of Sense to to to handle it not and I agree not like as a lens or a hermeneutic but
definitely as a way of just kind of pointing to like this is a process of destratifying right I mean
this is a process of um, you know, maybe maybe in this moment Plato was organizing like some kind
of intensities around this concept and it's and it seems really fixed and it seems really um intentional
but even in that moment that's gonna become knocked around and destratified by sensuality by sensual
relations and by the very process of structuring it right yeah yeah exactly exactly and and and that
is is also going to be an emergent moment where another body forms like oh there's another one you
know and it's like that's the Deleuzian battery yeah exactly and this is just an aside but like
who is Plato the person I mean this is an obvious statement but like there can't be a Plato behind
the writing I mean he was writing thousands of years ago we have no idea what he looked like what his
motivations were any of that so like writing is yeah he was a big guy he washes hair every day he washed it
every day loser what a loser his hair was always frizzy disgusting that comment wins the day
yeah but I mean you can do whatever you can do whatever you want with him the issue is that
there is the historical tradition at least in rhetoric of like cementing him in this one so you do have to
respond to that I guess it's in some way and react against that if you want to but I mean like
Derrida did you can do something interesting with Plato I mean why not it's it's there for the taking
it's just like I always think it's always weird to me when people talk about them as people as like
people we know Aristotle and Plato they're not people it's just text right yeah well they're words I mean
they're they're words that serve an organizing function right I mean this is Foucault on right
author stuff it's you know and yeah Plato is a word that has an organizing function a pretty big one
and certainly within the field of rhetoric and yes someone like Robin's book and other things like
that are are complicating the ways in which um those things get hurt and yet at the same time it's a long
process right like turning around an oil tanker doesn't take a book right yeah it's just uh so
so-called tradition changes um or again I mean I also when I really sit down and think about it I'm
like I don't even fucking know what the tradition I mean I you know when I'm really really serious
about it I use phrases like the I use phrases like the field yeah you know and phrases like you
know things like the discipline or whatever and I'm like but what am I actually talking about because
you know I'm just talking about I mean in Cady's terms like the sort of doxa that I hear at
conferences and that I occasionally read which is incredibly limited right it's just me and I don't
like reading so I don't read very much stuff you know so I I mean that it it makes just as much
sense to me really to go in and say look I recognize that a lot of people think that Plato is this
aristocratic leader blah blah blah but I also think that there are just as many people who think
that that's a that's a really reductive version that has done a disservice to the field of rhetoric
and that in fact we could reposition this whether philosophy likes it or not like we could reposition
this figure to do different kinds of intellectual work you know because it's there to be I mean this
is what this tells you if not Plato is that it it can't prevent itself this is where Zizek's
argument against Deleuze is like Deleuze is the thinker of late capitalism there's no I mean I think
his quote is there's nothing in the book Anti-Oedipus that prevents it from being taken up as a sort of
learning tool for Wall Street Wall Street traders and I was like that that's a good thing right like
there's nothing that prevents anything from being read there's nothing that prevents Nietzsche from
being the Nazi philosopher like and and Derrida is really great about insisting upon that is that
I'm not going to protect Nietzsche from having been appropriated by Nazis because all writing can go
anywhere it does go right like it and so anyone you know the the most sort of open-minded you know for
me personally that is the tyranny of the left these days is an emphasis on being open and it is it's
it's just as tyrannical and just as fascistic and just just as dangerous really you know to me so
Right, yeah, which doesn't make me fucking Jordan Peterson or some shit, right? Like, I mean
you know, you don't, you don't have farthest thing from Jordan Peterson. You're not telling
people to make their beds, you know, that's like the key to success, right? But I'm just, you know, you
know, I'm just saying, is like, look, no, there's there, I mean, and I, I take that to be one of the arguments
of Anti-Oedipus, right? Is that, uh, there are fascism of the, of the left, and they're just as real and
fascist as the fascism of the right, and they're just as scary and just as dangerous. I mean, I see, I see
it in my own little, you know, experiences through the world, like, that's some scary
shit that you're doing in the interest of liberation, which to me makes it way scarier
you know, it's, well, it's more subtle too, or at least for them, like, it, the, the issue always is for me, like
the illusion, uh, that you're not morally compromised, which is right, yes, the purity, yes. What people on the
or like certain theorists, uh, progressive people kind of tend to do is they assume the moral
high ground, which I'm not equating that with like the right, I mean, I think there's degrees of, of, uh
you know, moral ambiguity, but it is, it is at least just annoying when people assume that they're sort
of outside of that, uh, you know, moral engagement, whatever. It's the rebel alliance in Star Wars, right?
Like the rebel is the unquestioning good that always has a moral high ground, yeah. And so far, I mean, I saw, I
see it in response to the New York Times thing, like a couple of days ago, right? Like, every single one of
my friends has been posting about their support for, you know, the uh, women doctor position, you know, the
non-medical doctor thing, and I see this and on the one hand it's like yeah, I I actually quite agree with
that, right? Like, and I agree with the critique, this is a fucking moron who shouldn't it just should never
be published, right? The real issue is not that they're a moron wrote this, it's that the Wall
Street Journal published this. But whatever, that's money, I mean, I get it, you know, but but you see, I at
the same time that I see this kind of and feel an agreement or an alliance with this position that's
critiquing this, I also am like I feel like we're getting a little too uh, you know, full of ourselves
here and a little too comfortable with our self-righteous position, yes, you know, that that like
everyone is on board with this and we're so dismissive about it, like not not because there's value to it
but just like wait, wait, wait, let's settle down on the community building work that we're, that is
happening in response to this uh, New York Times op-ed or the Wall Street Journal op-ed, you know. So I think
this is how we might get undergrads to understand something like Logic of Sense is by scaffolding that
with demagoguery. Yeah, right, what's that's right. It is the perfect concept for foreign under anybody to
understand how there is no difference. Well, right, there's difference, there's difference, there's
difference, right? But but that you know there is, you know, that that game, um, of moral high ground
or taking the high ground, you know, it's just not, um, an option, and and or once you start playing it
you're playing the same game as everybody else, but that's exactly right. That was my response and I posted
on a couple of friends facebook's feeds is like guys, like, I mean, I I don't disagree with you, but
let's let's settle down here a second, like we are positioning ourselves now as these sort of
authorities who are being respectful of women because we call them doctor, you know? Right? Like, hold on a
second, let's exactly. There's so much to point there. There's there's not only the implications, there's
also the style in which people are putting out the support, you know, there's all of that is is
just the kind of stuff that we might critique if somebody else were doing. Absolutely, I mean, that's
the key point is like yeah, doesn't this doesn't the tone of this tribe sound a lot like the tone
of the tribe that you're, you know, like the the point is different. That's why I'm writing about style.
The point, the content is different, right? But the tone and the gathering of the forces and the incredible
like I didn't hear anyone, I didn't read a single person saying well hold on a second, let's take a step
like not a single person was saying. Everyone was jumping on to condemn the ridiculousness and I was
like hey tribes jumping on to condemn stuff that sounds familiar. Well nobody's able to like contextualize
their rage or even just their dispositions, you know, and for me like I tend to just not care about
everything, you know, or at least not feel personally invested in a lot of these debates, but I realized that
I mean at least recently I was like I think that that also comes from a place of privilege, you know
like if I were sure a marginalized person I would obviously be invested in some of these conversations
so my my being able to not care is because I hold a certain position now, but the point is like people
On any spectrum of the conversation don't seem to be able to make that move and just put their own
perspective into the larger context, you know what I mean? Right, I'm gonna, that's where it's a practical
question. No, but now you're, you're, you're doing the Hegel self-awareness move, right? Like you're saying
you know, you're, you're, you're a little bit more elevated because you recognize the extent to which
your position is embedded in a context, and if more people recognized that their position was embedded
in a context, but you just have the same problem at a different level, you know? Yeah, I don't think
I don't think I don't think it would solve the issue if every everybody was able to contextualize their own
opinions, but it would maybe, it would maybe make people less annoying, I think. It would make them less
annoying and less something that commentating is always less annoying, but I think that I mean I, I
right? Yeah, always. But, but I think to lose this, if we take to lose this point here is that
it's not less annoying, right? It's always going to work both ways. It's always like, that's the hard, that's
what I'm saying. I think it's hard to really get your head around, like it really is always going
to go both directions at once. It you can't ever try to to block the kind of retrograde. There's just no
possibility of that happening, that anything that you do and say is going to go, it's going to be larger
and smaller, you know? But I do think being aware of the tendency to calcify a position, which is sort
of the problem that we're talking about or around, like that even just the kind of general awareness
of that leads to a more interesting engagement, doesn't it? I mean, like as opposed to just calcifying
the opinion, right? You know, like, just I just don't think I just think it it becomes just as uninteresting
at a different level. Like I don't think that it's I mean, look for you and me. Yeah, right? Like I mean, for
us, right? Like, you know, people who like to think about public opinions, I think it's a more interesting
you do end up having a more interesting conversation, but I just think that the plot
problem is just going to redouble at a different level, like you're just never going to be able
in other words, I'm going to then say, well Nate's not sufficiently self-aware or he's contextualizing
himself in a very selective way. If he contextualized himself more fully, he would see, you know what I mean?
Like we're always going to end up playing that, that kind of right oscillating game. And again, the point
is not stop playing the game. The point is, I mean, at all, the point is that's the only game in town.
So you just play it, right? At some level you could say that this is a kind of argument against constant
self-awareness, against this sort of Hegelian elevation. It's like everything now returns to
the surface. Yeah, there's nothing to be gained. Like it's just another, it's just another right, it's just
another move in the game. It's not, uh, it's not a heightened level of meta awareness. Now meta is just
the new, you know, whatever, right? Like it's just the new, the new surface you're playing on. Exactly. It's
it's so interesting to think about, like I mean just the concepts that we could again these are just
attributes, right? So, um, the concept of of nonsense or the or or even the attribute of annoying, right? Is
is just a momentary configuration of certain intensities, right? Um, that is is fleeting and that is
you know, it's it's gonna be sensed and re-sensed as as people kind of come in and out of of that
in incensed incensed. Yeah, there you go. Exactly, exactly. So it's interesting that there's there
there are those concepts and then there are also kind of like these these concepts that we're using
almost in a kind of meta way to then judge the formation of those concepts. It's really I don't
know, it's interesting, which is yet just another sort of like intersection of forms on a flat plane that's
just going to create now a new, that's right, sense in a new direction. I mean, I to to not rescue but to
i mean, return to the the value of of self-reflection might I mean you would have to think of it as
flattened out, which is to say, like it's not simply better to do it but it does always create a unique
line of differences and if you if you posit it as better or higher then I agree though that the same
blockages are going to happen at at a different level, but if you flatten it out because the right
answer then is to say, well self-reflection doesn't do this thing that we thought we did so don't do it
but you're like no self-reflection is a variable that sort of that opens up a set of lines of flight
and and closes down others, like anything else, like anything, like anything else and unlike anything
else. Well, a distinctive, a singular right, a singular line of flight, but I mean everything is comprised of
lines of flight in that regard, so correct. It's singular, but this is where like this is that version of
elitism that you know that we're I think less comfortable with, which is if you only did this better
thing then everything would be better like if you only got educated and learn to better self-reflect
and learn to you know tame your doxa or you know civilize your your style then then you know the
the political body would be a better political body well that's right that you know we that was probably
true for in some configurations in some places but as soon as you universalize it you're gonna have
i mean have you seen all the calls for like in the last year or so i've seen so many calls for
renewing the enlightenment project right i mean because because to me i really felt like there was a
historical moment and i would mark it as like Adorno and those types of figures um for whom
you know the world war ii just marked the end of the end right it put paid to the idea the
Habermasian idea right that like more communicative rationality would lead to better right like think
people would be nicer and nicer and i've i've seen the sort of i've read you know the the end run around
that like well no we need more people need more education and i'm like oh my god like no right i mean
i thought we learned the lesson collectively that no education is not is not the solution
there there isn't actually a solution right shockingly there might not be a final solution
right that's that's right and we should have learned that lesson if nothing else it's a desire for us
it's a desire for a solution that is the dangerous yeah yeah you know exactly exactly i mean there's no
prescription here at least in these first two series certainly not but i mean there's definitely a
pedagogy i mean it you don't have to you don't have to call it reflection but he is encouraging and
attention to the dynamics he's laying out right i mean why would he write about them if if he weren't
like so the dynamics of language and then the the simultaneity of the of becoming and being that that
we've kind of uh outlined i mean he's he's asking us to look at that now whether we can like internalize
it or incorporate that into our disposition that's a that's a different question not even really a
necessary one but i mean i i do think i don't know i don't think it's as apart from the Hegelian move
as we might think or well i mean look it's there's a big difference between a pedagogy of climbing a
ladder and a pedagogy of uh go moving laterally on the surface and yeah and that to me is that's a big
fucking difference the the difference is the difference is not that one is a pedagogy and one is not
right they are both pedagogies and i agree with you to me pedagogy is
what i would be my term for the force of intervention you know um so it's a response um but it's it's not
a response in this sense i would say look there's a question of emphasis going on here in Deleuze
on the uh you know what we would call the bodies of that organ side or the going mad side or right
it's a question of emphasis while still not trying to maintain that other thing that he's writing he's
producing he's making he's not describing he's making right an intervention into into thinking
and it is a pedagogy in such and and all things in this regard are a pedagogy right everything that
you do say think is a pedagogy of something meaning it's an intervention into an existing system of
forces in order to configure them in one way or another and that's all i mean to me that's what
he's doing is he's saying here's what happens right here's how here's how things work there are just a
series of interventions into things so it's not it's not like hey people stop complaining about the Wall
Street Journal article um you know that's not necessarily my complaint right the complaint is
like look at how look at how the the problem replicates itself on the side that you'd think would know
better right but but but just doesn't right that that like okay so now it's our gang who's going to
you know whatever i mean so it's not i mean in that sense it's an intervention but it's not a
here's the right way of doing it but you just do what you do you do what you do that is i mean so to
point that out John i think is a an intervention but it's also a reflective it's a meta-reflective
intervention to say like hey look the thing that you're complaining about them we're doing the
exact same thing i mean you can only make that claim from taking the distance to be able to look
at sure sure sides so i want to ask this as a as a practical question then at the bottom of three
where um Deleuze jesus we already got to the third page we are moving i know where he i mean we kind
of touched on this earlier but where he again introduces paradox as a thing that destroys good
sense as the only direction but also that which destroys common sense as the a signation uh assignation
of fixed identity identities and i mean if i mean like what's not presumed that the function of good and
common sense aren't you know actual functions that operate on this flat playing and that they have
Pretty, you know, weighty, like they have quite a bit of of weight, and yes, they they rely on paradox, but
in some ways i kind of see this relationship as an invitation of sort of exploding their hold and one
way of exploding that, the force exploding, not exploiting, exploding but maybe exploiting um the force of the
common and the good sense would be to meta reflect and say, haha, see how this thing is the same as this
thing, but there would seem to be other, i think part of what Deleuze is doing here is is exploring other
mechanisms by which paradox sort of undoes and and destroys good and common sense, and one of the ways i mean
um nate you got me thinking about this is just the way that there's this interesting oscillation between
i mean look the two touchstones that he has in this book is Lewis Carroll and especially Alice in
Wonderland and then the Stoics right, and like this second series reads like a repetition of the first
but mobilizing but sort of like as taken up within this in this the topo way of the of the Stoics and
and like i i wonder if there's a a lesson to be learned in the way that he moves from these two
sites back and forth without trying to like there is a kind of sublation might be the wrong word for
it but i mean it's not a teleological progression but there definitely is a continuing ever evolving
sense in the way that these two um sort of like points are are revolving or orbiting around each
other right yeah that's a i mean that's a lot to throw out there as a question but i'm hoping it'll
i mean he he does seem to read the Stoics as like sort of proto deconstructionist thinkers right i mean
i don't know how the Stoics are usually taken up but they're i don't know if like would you call
could you say that the Deleuze is like saving the Stoics here in a way like or is he just mobilizing
them in a completely different way than they have before because i'd never read about the Stoics in
this uh like register you know what i mean neither have i this totally feared me the first time i read
this when he brought up the Stoics because i mean the Stoics and the Epicureans are only ever brought
up in my in my training which granted like you know my training and in this era was it was was pretty
limited to my undergraduate degree but it's only ever brought up in a sort of like within the context
of an explicit ethics never yes it really take i mean when you get like the glossary version of the
sort of like on like ontological metaphysical side of things with atomism and by um it's only ever a
gloss and it was interesting to me that he didn't like it didn't wasn't obvious that he was taking
them up in an ethical grasp but when you read the Williams book like that's the first thing he hits
you was like this is a book about ethics and life and but but i think that's a but but by the way like
at least in terms of my association with the Stoics truthfully it pretty much comes from this book so
like you know i haven't spent a whole lot of time with Marcus really you know like so i don't have that
sort of that kind of background but i think that's the point which is to say because they're ethical
thinkers first and foremost that's their ontology so the the baseline question here is not what stuff
is the cosmos made of but what do you do when faced with this problem right like and that's their
that's their starting point and they don't need a starting point prior to that or there's no need for
an investigation of the nature of matter in order to get to those questions of what do you do when
faced with a decision uh in life and that's exactly i think that's the starting that's the surface quality
is precisely we don't need any of that uh cosmology or the better way of saying would be all those
cosmologies presented themselves as preparatory for an ethics in a sense but they are just other terrains
of ethics right so that those cosmologies have historically lended a sense of the depth background
premises to ethical decision making right but they have never been anything other than ethical decision
making right when you're making a cosmology you're doing the same thing like you know what role should
god have here is functionally the exact same question is what do i do in this case right it is the same
question and that's i think what he locates in the Stoics is precisely the thing that you guys are
associating which is just that they're not real philosophers they're just sort of people who are
telling you how to live he's like yeah that's what real philosophy is so that's fascinating because
then he's kind of in some ways he's setting up in in knowing that this is going to be read right he's
setting up a performance where he's taking he's taking an ethic that is only sensible it is an only
sensible ethic right and what he's asking us is i mean well not asking but he knows what's going to
happen is in this encounter in this event um we are going to kind of we're going to sense that ethic
right it's because there's an there's an imminence there that's not that's right that will it's yet
to be right, um, and so to kind of go back to to the question of, you know, Dr. Jill Biden and and and
and what are we to do with with the style of engagement. I think Deleuze would just be like, actually, I'm
just really curious about the feeling that these people were trying to escape by forming this, like
yeah, staunch thing in this moment because that that sense, the response, yeah, yeah, there's like the
need for solid, the need for solidarity of women academics, right? Yeah, yeah, so I mean that's one of the
effects is that you have a kind of, you know, calcifying of women academics as an identity
I mean, not that it hasn't been there before, but you know, yeah, I don't think diagnosing responses
has to be metareflective either. I mean, I I don't think like we can think of that on the flat plane
as Nathaniel was saying, that Deleuze kind of lays out, right? I mean, it's just tracing responses and
the effects and the affects, uh, and how they, uh, you know, act on one another, so I don't think you have
to think of it as like I'm getting on top of my own response to this situation. No, no, you're absolutely
right, but that's why it's not Hegel because for Hegel you do, right? I don't I don't think I don't
it's not a ladder. Well, I mean, I do. We we don't. I don't know. I don't think we have enough time.
I think you can read Hegel differently just as you can read Plato differently.
Right, yeah, but I don't think you can get away from the notion, I don't think you, I mean, I don't think
you can get away from the notion of reflection as advancement and progress in Hegel, I don't think
that that you can say that that's not. I mean, you can say it but I mean, but it's a, it's a perpetual
interrogation of the capacity to err, you know, which is different from succeeding in a meta-reflective
move. Um, I I know that we've like kind of talked, you you think it's the two sides of the same coin
where it's like that's going on in The Logic of Sense here is that you like the the notion of of
airing cannot is is is not sensible without the possibility of right of success. I mean, I get that
which in which is like cannot help but bring in a whole teleology and and it means ends logic. Yeah.
No, I mean, again, that reading, the reading is valid. I I just think there is there's nothing but error
in Hegel, and I, and I think to a certain extent if you if you grant that then it's it's sort of the
same thing for Deleuze. I mean, like but he just chooses not to use the terminology. I mean, like there's
no success. What is it all success for Deleuze? No, there's no no, it's all success, it's all, and it's all
error, like yeah, there's no, I mean, it's just whatever happens is what happens. There's no progress.
See, I would I would say that, yeah, I agree. I would say that the the metric of success and error
is is nonsensical at the level of thinking, yeah, that's the flat plane of imminent that they are both
moves that that operate, that can operate, and frankly they can be disassociated with each other too
on the flat plane, but when when you start talking about them as the metric for judging the movement
of the dialectic, yeah, then they're standing outside of the thing, and even if the answer is always wrong
that the wrong answer is only ever possible in relationship to the right answer or the right
move, even if the right move is impossible, that the very possibility of of conceptualizing
the wrong response, the error, is only made possible because of even the impossible possibility of
of the the success, right? And that's to me, that's the difference is that, you know, even if
I I can I can divorce success and error from sort of like an evolutionary teleology where like you can be
like right, like course, like success and error at the level of correspondence, which you wouldn't have to think
about teleologically, um, and I could, but I I can't think of error without success at that sort of meta-reflective
from the perspective of the metric that is judging, right? I mean, I do think, you know, he kind of, you that
last passage at the end of uh page two, I think, um, where he talks about paradox being sort of essential
where was that? You read it, but uh, that was at the bottom of three that I read, but he said he brings
it up earlier, bottom of three. But I mean, paradox to me, first of all, this is interesting to like
ontologize that term, you know, so paradox is not just a word for a linguistic phenomenon, it's like it's a
structural phenomenon of like life, um, which is just kind of cool in itself and I don't think I've ever
really heard it used that way, but I do think, and this is you guys aren't going to like this, but
I do think that kind of presupposes the error success dynamic, right? I mean, in terms of the success of
individuation versus the error, the necessary error of the inconsistency of relations. Now again, you don't
need those terms. I just think they do kind of they slide in there if you want. I don't think there would
be any, there's no notion of a successful or unsuccessful individuation, right? Because
any individuation is also simultaneously a de-individuation, I think. I mean, I think that's
precisely the thing is that you can't be on one, more or less on one side of the movement than the other.
And where Hegel's always was to say, you're always on the wrong side, you're always erring, you're always
failing to totalize. There's like totalities off the table here, and so that's right, non-totality as
well, right? I mean, and and the the paradox, you know, he opens up with it like, you know, um, what does it
mean to say, you know, becomes larger? And what's its necessary relationship with becoming smaller? What does a
success or a failure even look like within that paradoxical because that's the paradox? The
simultaneous becoming smaller, larger, right? Like, right, let's let's have to introduce, let's stick with
that for a second. You said I because I I just went down that rabbit hole, and you said you did as well.
I'm curious what, I mean I'm sort of setting aside the Hegel question right now because for several
reasons, not least of which is that Katie wasn't subjected to us. We've had these
conversations for six months and uh Nate is interested in hanging on to a conceptual itinerary
that Nathaniel and I don't think that we want to leave behind. I think he's trying to say this
fairly. He could keep going with it, he could keep going with it as long as he puts as long as he slaps
a quote from Alice in Wonderland, right? Right? Right? And it's just in short course. It is the the logic of
you see it in Lacan and Zizek, the logic of the necessary failure to totalize that is subjectivity.
Right. You know, the reason everything is always contingent is because you can never fully totalize
this thing, and it requires it requires a presumption of an ideal totality. In Lacan it's the real uh that
at least hypothetically could exist, and and what Nathaniel and I are saying is that one of one of the things
that we like about the kind of Delusian itinerary is that there is no uh totality imagined, real, or
otherwise. So there's no success or there's no failure. I mean, it doesn't matter which term you use.
There's no success or failure. It's just right because there is no sort of idealized model that that's the
background for that conversation um but uh Nathaniel, I want to ask about like, so what did you come up with
in terms of because that really did I mean I really I was like, I'm gonna figure this thing out like what
is this what does this mean and by the way one of the things that interests me is my desire to figure
it out right my desire to what we would call that is resolving the paradox in other words to take the
paradox out of the realm of paradox, right? And make it into simply opposing doxes, right? And and not
simultaneous doxes. And there's by the way, I don't know if you if you read this Katie but there's an
article I came across. I cite it in the book but uh it's a really good article on paradox and it it goes
through like the types of paradoxes and it basically says the only true paradox is the ones that are
really really really unresolvable, and those are the ones that interest him here, and I I'll find it for
I'll find the site for you but it's really cool because he's like, most paradoxes really aren't paradoxes.
They're just sort of like you haven't thought yeah hard enough about them because if you think about
them you can resolve them and he's but the thing that he says in there, and this is the quote that I
think I took from him in the book is like, but if you stick with, and that's his phrasing, you have to
stick with the paradox, like stay with it as paradox, that's when it gets really interesting and I think
that's what's to lose us after here is if you stick with it as a paradox. In other words, don't do
what Nathaniel and I are about to talk about, you know, doing, which is like, I want to understand it. I
want to get my head around it so that I can say because I was able to resolve it and what did you
resolve it Nathaniel? What did you come up with for the Alice is getting bigger and getting smaller but
not at the same time because she's always getting bigger than she was but smaller than she will
become and so this is why the becoming always eludes the the present because as soon as you
articulate it within the present it ceases to be a becoming and it's a being but like what could what
could that um being ever look what could becoming ever look like as a being? It would have to have one
foot in the future and one that's right in the past, right? So there's like a kind of a stretching that
that that happens. So I mean, that's so yeah, it's like how do you that took me two hours it took him
30 seconds to say it, it took me two hours to figure that out, well John like Alice I have no interest
in books I don't have conversations or pictures
so that that's my uh I mean the reality is I've been trying to articulate that forever and I was like
pretty convinced when you asked me that I was just gonna go on like a word vomit for about
45 seconds and just say nothing because the only way i've i've tried i've been trying to yeah right
in the margins and i've like and this is you know like the first time i read i had it as a pdf and then
i finally got research money i could buy books and so this is the second time working through it
with with the book yeah like i mean it is amazing to me how much energy it takes just to
think through this at the sentence level and i have to really like get in the flow of the thing
because i tried reading it last night and it was just like words on a page and then when i re-read
it today it was like last night helped as a preparatory thing and then today i was able to actually
the the language that's why i started with the being and becoming stuff today is like the simultaneity of
the like to hype like part of the paradox is trying to hypothesize the the the becoming right coming
right because it's like well that means that she's bigger than she was and she's smaller than she will
become at the same time right which means that it she is in the state of not having fixed boundaries
as a state which is why that's this whole thing that's why i love this phrase about how all of this
contests alice's personal identity and makes her lose her proper name yep yep and what she hates
little boys because they're too deep they couldn't handle they get they get eradicated not Lewis Carroll
hates little boys is that in the section that we read today i think yeah right right because they
would just get their their depth would get eradicated by this they couldn't handle these paradoxes so
they would either ignore them or try to obliterate them or resolve them um yeah yeah this is what i was
saying with like but it it's it honestly she is made more fleshy as she is made less as as virtual
as possible she is literally virtual at the same time that you are thinking about cuts and you know like
it's so interesting to me that those limp those limits are just blah they're constantly yeah so i i
didn't follow you the first time but this time that makes more sense because i've been thinking about
like the image that i just showed where she's stretching and like there's this whole dialogue
that she has with herself and she's like and she can see she's not growing all that she's not growing
proportionally so she like she sees her feet and they're not proportional she is like that statue
they're not proportional to her head and she's like imagining having to send them
like gifts and a constantly like new sets of shoes like every so many seconds and she's imagining like
the letter that she would send them and then she notices realizes how ridiculous it is but i mean
you know but she is both losing the sort of like the conflation of her body with her name with
herself at the very same time that she's becoming sort of like far more conscious of her corporal
corporeality in its sort of stretching and bending which is that that's an interesting
uh juxtaposition i think totally so as in a sense it's like as she's losing a normative
conception of the body she becomes more bodily correct yeah right i mean that's what caddy said the like
10 minutes ago and i did not understand what she meant and then when she said it was like an hour and a
half it was like an hour and a half ago an hour and a half ago but that's cool this is what i'm saying
this book like i mean it's really honestly like to understand digitality like i would it's making me
think rethink like how would i teach digital rhetoric like i would i might start with these
Alice in Wonderland these two series and like you know QAnon
you